[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in the past i've made videos ranking the
most powerful gryffindors
slytherins hufflepuffs ravenclaws order
of the phoenix members
death eaters and more you guys seem to
really enjoy my ranking videos
so for today i'm going to be ranking
none other than dumbledore's army
i was thinking more of a name that
didn't tell everyone what we're up to
so we can refer to it safely outside
meetings
the defense association the d.a for
short
so nobody knows what we're talking about
yeah the da's good
only let's make it stand for
dumbledore's army because that's the
ministry's worst fear
isn't it i'm going to assume that most
of you know what dumbledore's army is
already
and if you don't well shame on you what
books have you been reading
however for the sake of the video i'm
going to provide a quick
refresher dumbledore's army was a secret
organization
first founded in october 1995 by harry
potter
ron weasley hermione granger and others
the purpose of the society was simple
teach hogwarts students how to properly
defend themselves dumbledore's army was
founded in the same school year that the
ministry of magic infringed on
dumbledore's power at hogwarts
which resulted in dolores umbridge being
appointed as the school's defense
against the dark arts professor
threatened and in utter disbelief at the
prospect the dark lord voldemort had
returned
fudge did everything in his power to
denounce and censor the prospect of
voldemort's return
this meant that the school's defense
against the dark arts class wasn't
really teaching students how to defend
themselves
which was a bit of an issue given that
voldemort had in fact returned
dumbledore's army was formed in response
to this lack of preparedness for the
imminent fight against evil
the trio who was certain of voldemort's
return knew that they needed to do
something to prepare their fellow peers
harry don't you see this this is exactly
why we need you
we need to know what it's really like
facing him facing
voldemort given that harry hermione and
even ron to some extent
were quite well versed in magic for
their age they took on the
responsibility
of teaching their fellow students
various spells that they could use to
combat the forces of evil
harry even knew how to produce a
patronus charm which was no joke for a
wizard of his age
when the organization was originally
founded it had 28 members
and though it disbanded by 1996 it had a
resurgence in 1997.
anyway without further ado i'm going to
be providing you with in my opinion
the six most powerful members of
dumbledore's army one important thing to
consider is these rankings are based on
the power
skill of the witch or wizard during the
time period that dumbledore's army was
first founded
not later in life i'm looking at 1995 to
1997. if we were to go buy power
rankings later in life then the list
would need some rearranging
maybe i could cover that video another
time number six
luna lovegood luna luna luna i think
it's best if we just let the book
describe luna
the girl gave off nora of distinct
dottiness perhaps it was the fact that
she had stuck her wand behind her left
ear for safe keeping
or that she had chosen to wear a
necklace of butterbeer caps
or that she was reading a magazine
upside down a known oddball luna
lovegood was born in the year 1981
to father xenophilius and mother pandora
lovegood
luna started at hogwarts one year after
harry potter in the year 1992
shout out to people born in 1992 and was
sorted into ravenclaw
house despite being a veritable oddball
luna was quite talented magically
most likely stemming from her
inquisitive nature though her presence
in social situations was a bit peculiar
luna knew a lot more about the magical
world than many gave her credit for
and as a result she was a powerful young
witch she was raised primarily by her
father xenophilius
as her mother tragically died
experimenting with spells when she was
just nine
however both of her parents were like
her magically talented but
simultaneously highly unusual
when luna joined dumbledore's army she
quickly learned how to produce a
patronus
and she was an extremely valuable asset
in many battles including the battle of
the department of mysteries
and the battle of the astronomy tower
number five ron
weasley i know what you're thinking ron
here's the thing
ron was always magically talented okay
maybe not immediately
but he became more and more competent as
the years went on the only reason that
ron's lack of skill ability was
sometimes apparent
highlighted was because he spent the
majority of his time with some of the
school's most powerful students
harry and hermione not only that but ron
came from a huge family of accomplished
and talented witches and wizards
this often left his own significant
accomplishments unnoticed
i'm the sixth in our family to go to
hogwarts you could say i got a lot to
live
up to bill and charlie have already left
bill was head boy and charlie was
captain of quidditch
now percy's a prefect fred and george
mess around a lot but they still get
really good marks and everyone thinks
they're really funny
everyone expects me to do as well as the
others but if i do it's no big deal
because they did it first however if we
look at ron as an individual
he was talented he really was and he
came into his own more and more as the
series progressed
when dumbledore's army was first founded
i feel that ron was really just starting
to realize his potential
and by the end of the deathly hallows no
one would be able to argue that he
became a truly talented
young wizard number four ginny ginny aka
geneva weasley
is a quintessential sleeper when it
comes to power as so sometimes shy
demeanor an unassuming appearance is in
stark contrast with her sheer power and
magical ability
yeah size is no guarantee of power look
at ginny
like ron jenny's skills develop as the
series progresses and by the time the
films end she's an extremely talented
young witch
when dumbledore's army was first founded
she quickly learned how to produce a
patronus charm
and in no time at all was adept at
producing other powerful spells
like reducto later in life jenny's
quidditch skills shone through more than
ever
as she eventually went on to become
captain of the holy head harpies
ginny is no joke number three fred
george
yeah i know this isn't one person but
honestly fred and george sort of
are one the powerful weasley twins were
born in the year 1978 and were sorted in
the gryffindor house
a few years before ron harry and
hermione the boys were funny
well liked among the student body and
much to the dismay of the teachers that
would be mused by their antics
very good students the boys were able to
produce advanced potions and spells
that were well above their pay grade in
terms of magical ability and were
invaluable assets in many battles
throughout the series
though fred tragically died and george
had to live out the rest of his days
without him
the boys were inseparable while still
alive which meant that their magical
ability was completely evenly matched
even if one of the brothers learned a
new spell it wasn't long before the
other brother knew how to do it as well
number two hermione granger number two
getting close to the top
hermione granger was one of the most
talented witches of her entire year
and the entire school for that matter
she began attending hogwarts at the same
time as harry ron
and given her affinity for learning
knowledge it's no surprise that she
became a talented witch
not only that but her work ethic was
impeccable as while attending school she
even went as far as to use a time turner
to take additional classes
she had a thirst for knowledge and
through her dangerous adventures with
harry and ron
became well versed in the practical
application of the knowledge that she
had amassed over the years
number one harry potter surprise
surprise harry potter
i don't think that harry's position on
this list should be shocking to anyone
as he was after all
the primary teacher of dumbledore's army
he was the first to learn a patronus
charm
and he was skilled enough at it to teach
other people harry certainly had a few
advantages
like the fact that a piece of a powerful
wizard soul was inside of him which may
or may not have influenced his power
but the thing that influenced harry's
level of power the most was that he was
hardened by his upbringing and
environment
harry was a fighter from day one and
after each altercation with voldemort
harry was a stronger version of his
former self i should mention
however that harry and hermione are
close i think that hermione probably
knew more about magic in general
including more spells but harry is quick
on his feet and an expert at
application harry just had too much real
life experience for another person of
his age to contend with him
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think how would you rank
dumbledore's army what do you agree with
disagree with
give me your list until next time
remember
there is plenty to be learned even from
a bad teacher what not to do
how not to be
[Music]
you